and no more kids that's it is that where
you stop him that's it we're asking you
my father are we stopping I want an
answer I want an exclusive are you done
for Real Every time I answer this
question it I can never answer it
correctly because
I don't know because and like one time
they asked me on entertainment I said I
leave it in God's hands and then all
these religious people got mad don't
break bringing Jesus into this never
mind God that's right don't break Jesus
into your foreign
let's make a prediction let's make it
I'm happy I'm happy currently with you
know my my daughter what if you but yeah
but it doesn't but what if you meet a
woman let's say right let's say um I
don't know who it would be and you fall
really cold yeah yeah I mean because you
gotta be amazing you know why she's got
to be amazing first of all she's got to
put up with all these other women and
all the other kids who would be the
woman that make you have a baby again
right now right off the top yeah I said
you could have any woman in the world
I sent you like like if I said to you
Nick Taylor Swift wants to have a baby
with you
that's the one that's I'm all in what is
it about her first of all she's an
amazing songwriter uh and what I do love
about Taylor Swift is the fact that she
has been so vulnerable and open with all
of her music since a young girl as and
she kind of like me like me and Taylor's
numbers is very similar when we're
talking about being in these streets
right so I think she would relate to me
very well based off of like yo you've
dated a lot of people in in the public
eye so have I so we probably will really
understand each other it has been
reported that Taylor Swift recently
broke up with her boyfriend yeah you
know I know that Howard you know I'm my
my Spidey senses was tingling I would
love if you had a baby with Taylor Swift
I think it would be me too yeah I think
that would be amazing
laughs